it seems like this might actually be
political because the things we would
expect from a burglary a typical
burglary area didn't happen
the property in question is is large
with multiple buildings on it and
without giving too many details away we
ultimately concluded that your typical
robbery wouldn't occur in a situation
like this I don't know exactly what
happened
um you know we just know that it did
uh that's what's been reported by well
we have the police report that was filed
the police took evidence and um the
reason why I want to bring this up is
that I've been talking about I talked
about this last week
we've been swatted uh several times and
we've not reported it uh everybody knows
that we've been swatted over a dozen
times at the bomb squad here and
everything like that and we keep being
told by uh people don't say anything
don't let anybody know what's happening
and and the first the first time I heard
that I'm like it's kind of odd like
shouldn't we let people know that there
are people trying to murder us